with major shipping backlogs all across
the nation you might think you're out of
luck if you haven't ordered your
christmas presents yet but fear not or
fear a little bit you can still get some
of your gifts in time we'll tell you
which ones in a moment americans are
spending are planning to spend an
average of 886 dollars on christmas
gifts this season that's according to
one recent poll but only a third of you
out there started shopping early david
kender is the editor-in-chief of
reviewed which is part of the usa today
network and he joins us for some tips on
last-minute shoppers david good morning
to you i think the first tip needs to be
what products if you're aware of them
are still available today and will
arrive by christmas
well it's it's spotty uh you know
shipping delays were going on into a
year and a half now and it's been
very hard to find
you know things with microchips and and
uh and and that's impacted so many
different kinds of products from toys to
cars to
appliances and so
i think the best advice that we can give
is that you just keep your options open
and that you expect to pay a little bit
more if you are one of those last-minute
larry's i want to get to i'm glad you're
picking this is going to become a thing
by the way nate they're going to become
a thing i like it too david i want to
get to the cost question but are there
particular retailers that you can think
of that are particularly good at getting
gifts out at this time of the year
yes so
even though today is the 22nd and your
options are shrinking the world is no
longer your oyster as a gift buyer there
are options
amazon is of course one that a lot of
people are going to go to first and you
can order on amazon through tomorrow
but it's not going to be for every
product and it's not going to be you
know anywhere in the country that you
live so the best thing you can do is
just go to that product page and over on
the right hand side somewhere around the
upper right hand corner it's going to
give you an expected delivery date but
expect to pay a little bit more and you
may have to be an amazon prime member a
little bit more means what these days
yeah right
um it can be a few bucks to
um target is another really popular
place where people are buying gifts they
actually own a shipping company called
ship s-h-i-p-t
and for 9.99 you're actually going to be
able to get same-day shipping so you can
buy from target.com
on december 24th and have that product
shipped a few hours later but again not
every product and not every market
walmart is another store where they're
telling their customers they can do
same-day shipping
if you order from walmart.com
all the way up through
1pm on december 24th and they're going
to be able to get it to your house in a
few hours but i would really recommend
people not wait that long
yeah normally a little bit more david
means an arm a leg and a spleen i was in
the store the other day and they told me
the price i go well it's okay if it gets
there on the 26th but listen it always
happens christmas always comes december
25th every year and a lot of us always
find ourselves in this position you're
now saying you should order online and
then have an in-store pickup which i
think is a really great suggestion for
people i didn't know yeah the acronym
that you want to uh you want to remember
is bopus
buy online pick up in store it's a great
strategy because of all these shipping
delays you can absolutely just walk into
a store right now but you don't know
what they're going to have
so you can buy it on the website and
then pick it up in store and of course
that opens up a lot of options because
you don't need to worry about shipping
then you have target walmart plus stores
like best buy
nordstrom
home depot michaels macy's you're gonna
have a lot of options there
now reviewed has researched a lot of
gifts that don't require shipping like
digital subscriptions so what are some
of the best gifts for the holiday season
yeah the thing that i love about the no
ship gifts is that it takes all the
stress out of shipping entirely and a
lot of these are subscription services
where
the gift arrives in january and then it
arrives again in february and march and
you have products like
um
like books.com which is a flower
delivery service you have book of the
month club wine of the month beer of the
month i got beer the month once i loved
it
and it's a great little way for um for
the person to feel you know a little
extra love it's like a little extra hug
that that they get but can i i'm not the
expert here but i would recommend if
you're getting a subscription gift you
need to wrap like the confirmation and
put it in a box under the tree so
someone has something to open correct
otherwise check your email you'll be
excited it's not a good doesn't work
morning because part of the fun is
opening yeah david i like your beer of
the month i would have thought you were
a rose guy so i like beer the mom works
for you i like it david kender thank you
really good to see you